un retrato de pura desesperación tomada
en el mar del norte este miércoles
muestra a un migrante aferrado a la red
que cuelga de la parte trasera de un
barco de arrastre mientras él y muchos
otros intentan llegar al reino unido-
las travesías en botes de goma como
estos se han multiplicado recientemente
y los rescates también con más de 400
recuperados de forma segura el miércoles
300 del día anterior números inéditos
según los servicios de emergencia al
menos 2 migrantes han muerto en los
últimos días estos jóvenes kurdos
estaban entre los salvados derecho a
crear un gueto what you tube wood había
demasiada gente en el barco este volvió
con el agua hasta aquí estuvimos en el
mar dos horas fue demasiado llamamos a
la policía y vinieron los helicópteros
michael polish el turco en el norte de
francia cerca de dunkerque alrededor de
1000 están esperando su momento en este
campo improvisado cada vez más mujeres y
niños están cruzando antes de que
empeoren las condiciones invernales y
así si lo intentes pero no pude hacerlo
6 o 7 veces me ha parado la policía y me
ha capturado
la policía está ahora más alerta y
activa en un intento de disolver los
campamentos improvisados estás imágenes
de la semana pasada les muestran
destrozando las tiendas de campaña de
los migrantes para los activistas esto
es inaceptable por lo que dos de ellos
llevan más de tres semanas en huelga de
hambre en señal de protesta 1 l no se
debería dejar a la gente dormir a la
intemperie sin siquiera darles una carpa
y menos quitándose las autoridades han
ofrecido una noche de alojamiento de
emergencia a estos migrantes antes de
facilitarles el transporte a otros
albergues una oferta a menudo rechazada
por quienes no han arriesgado todo para
llegar tan lejos